the jurgen experience
when you were done with the paperclip
book and you know you you published it
and you have to live with all the
information that you had to gather and
and run through your mind did that book
was that
the book did that change you that book
like was it the most
altering of this different subjects that
you covered
i mean each book has a huge impact for
different reasons but when i think of
paper clip i think of this one saying
that was over the gates
of buchenwald and it was it said yadam
das
zaina and what that means is everyone
gets what they deserve and that
was horrible and i still think about
that because it's such a piece of nazi
propaganda it's like saying to the jews
you guys deserve this
and so i know much of my reporting and
my generalist way of being as a human is
there's no such thing as what you
deserve
right there's what there's what happens
and there's what you do there's what
you're responsible for and there's what
you can change
but there's that idea is reprehensible
for some reason that really stuck with
me
as the as just the worst possible thing
that i could think of jesus because it's
the psychology behind why they did what
they did yes
the dehumanizing but the weird thing is
that that was
less than 100 years ago that seems like
that should have been something that
took place if you hear about the
inquisition you go okay well that makes
people didn't know any better back then
but 1945 is not that long ago it's just
not
i mean people people just read and read
and read about world war ii
for good reason you know and everything
i write starts
it all goes back to the nazis and every
book
i the the trail the paper trail at the
national archives or
individual university libraries and
people's papers where i go
they all refer back to that because it
was so remarkable that the nazis led
in weapons technology and they almost
took over the world because of it
right and that is the premise of all of
this i mean in surprise kill vanish it's
like
these are the guys on the ground in the
pentagon's brain it's
this is the technology in the sky but we
must
we the government's position whether
it's pentagon
cia is always we have to stay ahead
because
the next nazi germany is right around
the corner yeah
and that's a that's really something to
think about is that alarmist
i don't think it is history repeats
itself i mean ha if we
went and stopped and looked at all the
instances throughout history of people
being evil dictators
there's quite a few and there's you know
we've we could look at north korea right
now
and that guy assassinated his own uncle
right with a
what was that with a missile coming out
of a helicopter i think
put him in a field yeah yeah
i mean that's straight-up messaging yeah
right which is another thing i think is
interesting about
the cia's paramilitary program it's all
meant
to remain plausibly deniable it's
supposed to be secret
like we're not supposed to be giving out
the message that we have these
teams you know that go after high value
targets
right they're just supposed to disappear
that's the vanish part of the
so that and that as someone who is
really
interested in transparency and people
being educated and having information
that always puts me in conflict with you
know the government in essence because
i'm
i'm like we should know but then you
think about it well the whole thing is
you were not supposed to know because
it's supposed to be just
the hidden hand the president's hidden
hand they call it what has to be this
distinction that they have the ability
to break the rules because that's
how they protect us i mean that that's
that's the rub right and the stories we
hear
are often the failures because those are
the ones that get reported in the press
there is a sense undergirding this
narrative which i
really like and am interested in and
intrigued by is that
the the successful operations you don't
hear about
because they're plausibly denied
right yeah there's got to be a ton of
them that went through
that you don't hear nothing about and
your kids will hear about it
maybe when you think about protecting us
from
something like another nazi germany
that's when people are willing
to give up some of their freedoms
they're willing to give up
surveillance they're willing to give up
and this is this is where things get
real slippery right
i mean also when you think about russia
because all of this cold war
science technology operations all of
that was
to beat back the russians okay then the
russians go away and now they're back
you know the russians are the master
assassins
and they do it through poisoning i mean
look at skirpal right
i write in the book about a defector who
came over
in the 50s and said i was an assassin
for the kgb
and gave us all kinds of information
it's fascinating to look at those
documents and realize like
this is how it works this is how it
worked you know
60 years ago and then you kind of see
echoes of that of how it's working
today and you can only imagine
the defectors or those who come over
from the other side
who we learn from and they just
disappear
into i mean they disappear as sort of
the cia's version of witness protection
[Applause]